Female foam-nesting tree frogs build frothy
nests at the ends of tree branches that extend
over small bodies of water.
They do this by secreting a watery substance
and whipping it up with her hind legs, which
quickly gains the attention of nearby males.
It’s in this foam bath that a male will
copulate with the female.
Oh!
Did I say male?
I meant MALES - up to 20 additional males
will join the party in quick succession, earning
female foam nesting frogs the title of ‘most
promiscuous’ females in the vertebrate world.
The males and the female will all continue
the leg-pumping, frothing action, which serves
to increase the size of the nest.
The lengthy orgies are generally peaceful,
and the majority of a female's’ eggs are
fertilized and well-protected in their foamy
environments.
But in addition to taking a LOT of energy,
it seems that having such promiscuous sex
could be downright dangerous for female foam-nesters.
The possibility of competition between males
or the potential for injury to the female
seem like they could be major factors here.
Why would these females take the risk?
Foam nesting frogs live in stochastic South-Eastern
African environments.
This means that the environmental conditions
are both unpredictable and also quite severe.
By allowing each of her egg clutches to be
sired by a variety of males, a female ensures
that her offspring will be genetically diverse.
This diversity will allow at least some of
her babies to survive, regardless of the environmental
conditions that they will have to endure.
In this way, when mom acts like a supertramp,
she is actually making sure to maximize her
own genetic blueprints in future generations.
Who are we to judge?
Want more videos about animals made out of
paper, check out this playlist from our friends
at The Dodo.
Don't forget to subscribe and keep coming
back to Seeker for more videos.